Story time.
This reminds me of when I first started building things with wood.
So, I went down to Home Depot.
I bought some wood.
I bought a hammer and a box of nails, and suddenly I could build things.
I went crazy with it.
I built all kinds of small things,
occasionally hitting my finger, but generally, I was successful.
Eventually though, hammers and
nails didn't quite cut it, so I saved up some money and I upgraded.
I bought a screw gun and some screws.
I bought a chop saw.
I even bought some of these.
And I built all kinds of cool things with these tools, and
the things I built were much better because my tools were better.
Then I wanted to build an actual structure, like something I could stand on.
And guess what?
I didn't trust my own designs.
I knew that if I took my methods from all those small projects and scaled them
up, I'd build something that wouldn't hold my weight, which would be bad.
Now, I didn't need to go out and buy new tools.
I had everything I needed, everything physical at least.
What I did need was some organizational guidance and
some new building techniques.
So, I spent some time experimenting.
I discovered that if I separated out my sections of my project into
different pieces that attach to each other, it'd be easier to build,
potentially more stable, and much easier to change later.
Then eventually, I Googled around and I got even better techniques that way,
things that would have taken me a long time to figure out on my own.
And this is exactly where you are right now.
You have great tools.
You know JavaScript.
You know the features of the language.
But you do need to learn better organizational techniques so your applications
are stable and bug-free, cleanly written, they scale well and are extensible.